hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to we're bunnies fly I
shouldn't need to explain why this game
must be played look it's a freaking sad
looking little bunny in a hot-air
balloon
trying to go through that goddamn
rainbow it's like an adorable so I
found this game because apparently it
has a high score ranking system on
gamejolt where I found it and you know
me I am here to try to get the best
score possible in absolutely every oh
I'm going okay I don't know how to play
whoa oh it's beautiful
Oh gopanna player go oh harvest eggs
Easter eggs from the clouds now I don't
know entirely how that works but I think
I spot one up there I'm coming for you
eventually before I run out of fuel oh
it's not gonna get there is it I just
want one yay did I get it
ahh what feel empty I got it okay
alright restore ten fuel per egg
delivered I don't know what that how
whoa Mountain Oh first delivery achieved
yay I don't I don't have fully
understand I think I need that carrot
for fuel I don't think I'm gonna make
that I don't know how I'm gonna make
that but I don't think I'm gonna be
I'm not gonna do that
find a care before you crash oh no is
there a chance of blood applier here
dying I didn't know that was part of the
contract I thought I was gonna be
totally okay oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die oh God
incoming bunny baby oh ah god damn it oh
I thought it was gonna be a horrible
explosion and then bunny bits were gonna
be strewn across the valley I must get
the high score no matter what hit yeah
okay just got to conserve it so that oh
I gotta follow the slipstream
oh there's slip strahm's whew okay so oh
geez I'm not gonna get up high enough
for
or I MRI ah tits I missed it
goddamnit how can this be so hard ah I'm
gonna miss the rainbow oh look at the
little blonde born oh he's so cute
whee I don't know how to play no I don't
know what I'm doing
can I get that yeah I can get that yeah
yeah okay
whoa it's like a crisscross nightmare of
slipstream that's going on here
okay so if I can ride this up I can
probably get two more upward speed yes I
can combo a few okay up up up up up up
ah come on I so had that who get this
one honk okay well there's one hidden in
the closet
oh I'm out oh I don't know how to do
that deliver to the rainbow portals I'm
not gonna be able to get that I don't
have enough carrot power to be able to
go any farther
I'm funner knocked have a goddamn stupid
stranded baby bunny baby bunny bunny
baby
okay so restore 10% fuel per egg
delivered which means that I'm probably
gonna be able to get a little bit of
fuel back but I don't know about the I
don't know about the manga manga
bah-ruch okay so I got some fuel I got
to be very conscious of it very very
jeez there's carrot I can make it ah I
can make it
oh I can make it I can barely make it ah
I was right there I was right on top of
the plane
booze black man bunny bits everywhere
okay so I'm getting the hang of it
everybody bear with me but I'm gonna get
the hang of this and then I'm gonna win
this you're gonna see you're gonna see
the high score bunny man the expert
bunny maker that is me I'm the best
bunny the best biggest bounciest bunny
with the biggest bazooms whoa got a
carrot nice increase full caboose d-cup
loose glue maybe it's like a fool's
errand to go up cuz I saw I can't
control the camera by the way so I saw
hmm I saw right there right there okay
don't go slow nice and navigate it land
it eat it munch it down cram it in your
face Wow
oh yeah I got it I got it okay I didn't
know if I got it or not
okay so I'm gonna follow the slipstream
up in the rainbow and then I'm gonna be
able to get up into the clouds and be
able to get what I need
slipstream it slipstream it twitch
stream it damn it that's not enough
there's a sip stream over there going
straight up I'm gonna go for that one
yeah go go go baby go
woo rising rising not enough though good
morning ah come on okay bonk
that's one there was another over here I
saw another one oh geez okay I'm up
above I'm way high up okay I think I can
get this one oh come on it's right there
okay at least I can refit why ah damn it
I know this is not the time for a
slipstream I need to go for this carrot
or else I'm gonna be dumb oh where to go
oh there it is okay so I can go down all
right we got this carrot find a carrot
before you crash I got it I got it I can
keep this up indefinitely if I stop
sucking so badly on the world's greatest
sucking bunny here we go locked on
target
locked on target no ah rise okay so
that's good man we got a lot o 50% fuel
capacity holy that's a lot why is
it so generous why am I so suspicious of
how generous it is okay I'm gonna not go
for that one I'm gonna go for these up
here this cloud cluster yes yes
BAM got it okay that's another one I
can't see any more up cuz of camera
angles got shitty tits okay
wait just one it oh I
ah there's one in there it's one of the
goddamn clouds here I saw it that damn
and I saw I saw it no I saw it goddamn
it
damn slip streams I don't need this much
I don't I don't need this much stream
slipping I'm the most lubed air balloon
in the sky oh boy oh try dog that I
can't go backwards can i but I can go
down to that one down there and then hop
jump to that one oh I can do a triple
ooh baby a triple heavy load I don't
have a heavy load not right now anyway
and we're not gonna talk about the
connotations of what that statement
meant shut up it did boink okay that's
another one okay so I have to get this
one wink ah who's the bunny master all
I'm gonna get a quadruple no I was gonna
get it quit drew oh there was another
one hidden in the goddammit hmm
barbar knocking peaches I can't
believe how seriously I'm taking this
stupid game about actually it's not
stupid at all usually I'm sarcastic and
I say the game's stupid just because I'm
not it's not going my way but there's
actually it's really pleasant I mean I
imagined it'd be more pleasant if I
wasn't screaming like an idiot but I
can't help it because I want to win but
it's just really pleasant to see like
how nice it is you're just it's
literally the only objective is to
collect Easter eggs in the clouds this
is like a fever dream but it's my kind
of fever dream I like this a lot
ooh and I believe it's probably this
whole mountain mountain mountain yes yes
mountain mountain mountain okay
and I believe like this is my kind of
fever dream it's just I believe it's an
infinitely generated landscape too which
is awful like a really cool little
feature about this game and it's
beautiful its stylized I mean it's not
like super high polycount amazing
graphics but in its own way it's
stylized to be perfect to what it is and
that's that's all I really asked out of
games is that it is what it should be
and this game is just so pleasant anyway
that's all this that's all the thoughts
I have about the game itself back to my
screaming like an idiot
come on I was so close damn it is gonna
be a death-defying one when I have to
curtail the mountains pull a hay hang a
sick Yui Oh get up up up up right ye ah
Oh
snark ease woo that is not a lot of
control I have there holy holy
oh come on give me that one
give me that one give me if you'll give
me fire give me that one no damn it I
wasted all that fuel for nothing I
thought I was gonna be able to get that
goddamn it of course it's gonna waste my
time but maybe I can drift down on the
top of this mountain then scrape down a
few eggs what the hell am I saying god
I'm strategizing about this but it just
sounds like I'm totally out of my mind
I just float my bunny in the balloon
down this mountain grab a few more
gigantic Easter eggs yet magically
shrink into my basket
nobody drifts down through another
rainbow that's gonna shoot me off into
this guide it's going to be great better
be careful and get four more carrots so
I don't run out of fuel because
everybody knows if you burn carrots it's
at a double rainbow oh oh it's so
beautiful
hmm here we go Oh thread the needle baby
oh yeah fuel refilled thank you very
much yeah gotcha whoo almost got killed
oh that's a trap oh it is a trap rainbow
rainbow trap okay so I don't believe
this game has an end I believe this game
is just meant to be played to get his
high scores you feel like it and it
seems to me like once you get the hang
of it you can really keep going forever
like I don't see how I could die unless
I get crammed into a very precarious
situation but it's really cool I like
this game a lot and it's the second
bunny game that I played in recent time
I think Oh apparently that didn't even
kill me so it's got to be totally fun so
let me know what high score you can get
out of this game it's totally free to
play by the way and maybe you can log
your high scores on gamejolt itself so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye somewhere over the rainbow way
up high there's a bunny in a basket
collecting Easter eggs up high somewhere
okay bye